16 17 18 rails et il ya déjà 18 jours
que je n'ai pas fait le ménage chez moi
bon je vais profiter dans l'instant de
tranquillité pour faire le ménage à faux
par
[Musique]
op et voilà il ne faut jamais rangé un
balai avant de l'avoir secoué
[Musique]
et voilà un cadeau de casimir pour
léonard
léonard a oublié son livre de fables de
la fontaine
j'adore les fables de la fontaine
laquelle les lire aujourd'hui
le loup et l'agneau la raison du plus
fort est toujours la meilleure mais
c'est très intéressant ça d'autant plus
que je suis moi même très fort un
le loup et l'agneau
la raison du plus fort est toujours la
meilleure nous allons montrer tout à
l'heure en agneau se désaltéraient dans
le courant du nom de purin un loup sur
20 agen qui cherchait aventure et que la
faim en ces lieux attirer qui te rend si
hardy de troubler mon breuvage dit cet
animal plein de rage tue sera châtié de
ta témérité
si l'on répond l'agneau que votre
majesté nos sommets de points en colère
mais plutôt qu'elle considère que je me
vois des alter en plus le vin par ou
dessous d'elle et que par conséquent en
aucune façon je ne puis troubler sa
moisson tu as troubles à dix reprises
c'est tout bête cruella et je sais que
de moi tu mets 10 l'an passé
comment l'on rajoute fait je n'étais pas
né repris lannion je t'ai encore ma mère
si ce n'est toi c'est donc ton frère
je ne lis points c'est donc quelqu'un
détient car vous ne vais pas renier
guerre un nouveau berger 0 siens aux
mains l'a dit il faut que je me range à
rades suis au fond des forêts
le loup l'emportent et puis le mange
sans autre forme de procès à quelle
table superbe j'ai vraiment beaucoup de
talent
si douce top en plein travail ah oui et
céramique quelle beauté quelle harmonie
de couleurs chacune de ces ces mesures
sont vraiment remarquables
vous avez raison monsieur du snapo c'est
un des plus beaux paysages que je
connaisse pardon j'ai remis je ne
parlais pas du paysage mais bon petit
jeune
tout à l'heure un city-stade
sa luge salut casino
du snav veuillez vous déplacer je vais
par la belle écuyère mois quasi muet
mais tu préfères un petit pas sur le
côté non je souhaite aller par là et
c'est à vous que vous déplacer essayez
de réfléchir une fois que tu verras que
j'ai raison pas toi tu peux faire
quelques pas tandis que moi quand je me
lève que déplacement au matériel mon
tableau mon cheval est mon ma chaise
était comment attendez une seconde
devrait vérifier quelque chose
julie oui excuse-moi quasi magie bono
grave juste une question jusqu'où je
suis plus fort que monsieur du snav
c'est tout merci
monsieur 10 nabawi suis plus fort que
vous oui la raison du plus fort est
toujours la meilleure
à bon entendeur salut mais il est fou
ce que vous êtes douillet
je voudrais vous y voir ouzou sous les
pas d'un monstre préhistorique faux
furieuse
je voulais toujours dit que c'était un
être dangereux d'ailleurs il n'aime pas
d'après tu
n'es pas mais il n'aime pas mes oeuvres
d'art c'est vous dire combien il est
gros balourd et sauvage donc un être
dangereux ou si du snob vous vous avez
rencontré casimir poma le et bien
mademoiselle futaies et monsieur travail
mi-longs teints aussi rencontrer ils
sont dans le même état que monsieur 10,9
mais alors il est venu compliquer
montfort que vous disais non non non
casimir n'est pas devenu fou mais j'ai
la clé du mystère raconte vite qui a
tout à l'heure je suis passé chez
casimir pour lui demander une
explication n'était pas là mais le livre
des fables de la fontaine de léonard
était resté ouvert à la fable le loup et
l'agneau casimir l'a certainement lui
ainsi que sa morale qui est la raison du
plus fort est toujours la meilleure et
comme casimir se laisse influencer
facilement mais oui je me souviens
maintenant tout à l'heure avant de vous
ont versé il est venu me demander si à
mon avis monsieur dit saab étaient moins
forts que lui
lui donner une bonne leçon mais j'ai une
idée à bout voir ce qu'on a fini
à papa mon papa je suis le plus beau le
plus fort et j'ai toujours raison vous
vouliez me voir je crois oui oui nous
avons une petite question est posée je
veux bien vous écouter ou par les
audaces
casimir est ce que tu es plus fort que
gély monsieur du snob et moi bon enfin
c'est vraiment une question idiote c'est
évident et bien voilà pourquoi je te
poser cette question et dix autres
gardes voilà un beau les géants de cloud
by bull car nous sommes persuadés tous
les trois que le gloubiboulga temple a
tellement mauvais qu'il faudra jeter
nous sommes certains d'avoir raison et
bien malheureusement pour vous je suis
certain que le gloubiboulga est
délicieux la preuve c'est que j'aurai le
manger de nommer les roms je suis le
plus fort j'ai raison tu vas tu va
d'abord doit d'abord nous prouver que le
plus fort comment es tu vas nous le
prouver au jeu de la corde tient à
casimir du tir de ce côté de la corde
julie monsieur justin biennois nous
tirons de l'autre côté c'est enfin comme
je suis le plus fort sam ouvrira
l'appétit à l'oser
cigaliers
comprend ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
suis pourtant le plus fort en vol il aux
enfants casimir tu viens d'apprendre une
nouvelle maxime
l'union fait la force
vous n'allez quand même pas jeter son
bon jovi brouillard et non pas une issue
bien casse
toi ah merci mes amis
[Musique]